only so anyway back to the equity thing
of all the preposterous and idiotic
ideas so first of all to make gender
equity across every dimension of a an
organization who have to assume that men
and women have identical interests or an
temperament and that if they don't the
state should intervene to bloody well
ensure that they do which is something
for all young women to figure out
because now there's many many what
positions in society that women
preferentially occupied so what are you
going to do about that and what are you
going to do about the ages because they
occupy preferential positions as well
you know they're over-represented in all
sorts of professional institutions and
the probability is that that point does
increase what about that what about the
Jews what are going to do about this
because they have they're at the same
position as the issues you know put
quotas on all those people what kind of
stupidity is that and then it's worth to
because let's say you equalize women and
just for the sake of argument across all
these different dimensions of society
well then what are you going to do is
are you going to equalize for black
women and as Latino women and Asian
women are even expose type black women
but it's not like they're all the same
are you going to ensure that women from
lower classes in her car represented
just as much as women from upper classes
and how many generations backs are you
going to go to chips up what about
intelligence what about attractiveness
how about Heights how about weight so
the problem with the fractionation by
group identity is that it's endless
there's no way of ensuring equality
across groups comes as an incident
number of groups you can frighten that
group identity all the way down to the
level of the individual which is exactly
what you should do which is what we
already did in the West we figured well
the ultimate diverse population is a
population of individuals so you let the
individual sorted out no no we can
replace that with group well what that
means for the bloody social activist is
that they'll be able to play this game
forever because you can continually
fracture the group by
entity ad nauseum n so the system will
never be equal and you can bloody well
be sure that as we implement social
policy to make sure that all outcomes
are equal but the amount of space that
you personally are going to have to
maneuver in it's going to shrink and
shrink and shrink and shrink we've
already seen that happen in many
societies you think we would learn from
the 20th century